i've got to ask you what do you think of
uh
what would your great grandfather have
thought about how your action on
uh trying to get countries to recognize
the armenian genocide leads you to
be in armenia like you said doing that
gig and then being welcome to some kind
of hero because not only
if you made enough enemies talking about
uh
turkey's crimes as you see it you then
criticize
post-soviet oligarch corruption in
armenia
i look the in 2018 armenia experienced
a very unique uh positive event for our
history it was the velvet peaceful
revolution of 2018
we um i've helped document documented in
another documentary called i am not
alone
and you know um i've i've been very
active
politically against injustice everywhere
in the world whether it's in the us
whether it's around the world
always speaking truth to power if you
will and and
armenia as well you know we had a
post-soviet oligarchic
uh really corrupt regime that really
stifled
people's uh vision you know um uh there
they couldn't get justice in the courts
they acted with their feet as they say
and they left the country there was a
lot of depopulation
and it was very very it was a horrible
situation
you